jump jump jump jump jump jump
löw meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer iphone vanilla
mod in minecraft ja ihr habt richtig
gehört das ist jetzt nicht irgendein
komische mod die man sich jetzt
installieren muss oder irgendetwas
komisches einfach nur gebaut sondern es
ist einfach nur eine map die ihr euch
downloaden müssen ihr müsst nichts
irgendwie mit ford installieren und zwar
wird es wie ich finde beste iphone
bisher hinzugefügte seht schon da oben
läuft die zeit wir können flecki birds
spielen wir können notizen machen wir
können payne wir können die farbe ändern
und und und ich hab schon extrem viele
iphone ipad apple motto auf youtube
gesehen und die fand ich jetzt alle
nicht so toll dass man die vorstellen
könnte allerdings ist das hier etwas von
einem deutschen youtuber entwickelt vor
zwei monaten oder eineinhalb monaten ist
es glaube ich raus gekommen und ich
dachte mir ich stellt euch einfach mal
vor den link dazu und in der
beschreibung ist auf jeden fall den
kanal abonnieren macht zwar die videos
auf englisch aber auf jeden fall mal
vorbeischauen und zwar läuft das bei mir
hier gerade alles schon wenn ihr
allerdings die welt download ist bei
euch bestimmt erst mal der komplette
bildschirm schwarz
und dann müsste hier erst mal drauf
drücken beziehungsweise einfach dagegen
fliegen dann sehe ich ein iphone six bei
craft roddicks dann sehen wir da unten
blendet sich an apple logo ein und
danach öffnet sich ganz normal der
homescreen hier müssen natürlich die
renndistanz auch vorstellen und dann mal
ein bisschen mehr anfliegen damit das
ganze auch verändert allerdings wenn bei
euch da nichts passiert und das immer
noch schwarz bleibt den fehler hatte ich
nämlich her
erst dann hatte ich mich ein bisschen
informiert dann müsst ihr nämlich hier
unten hin gehen und hier mal gegen
fliegen und dann vierter nämlich gleich
so ein charging kabel warte ihr müsst
erst hier gegen den homebutton fing ich
weiß nicht ob ich jetzt überhaupt
starten kann weil ich ja doch es geht
so jetzt bin ich quasi hier drin
eingesperrt jetzt muss ich mich hier mal
kurz raus bauen so und dann sehe ich
schon ist jetzt ein ladekabel
aufgekommen
und dann wird euer iphone quasi charge
bei mir ist es jetzt folge charged und
da muss jetzt nicht unbedingt was
geladen werden aber das ist auf jeden
fall nur so wenn bei euch wirklich der
anfang screen quasi black ist einfach so
freunde da ich gerade einfach bei diesem
slide code so dran her geflogen bin
quasi direkt vor der vor dem bildschirm
müsste ich jetzt mal den code eingeben
der code ist 000
0 den kombi natürlich nachher auch noch
ändern sonst würde ich euch natürlich
nicht vorstellen lässt sich gehen würde
so ich flieg davor ihr seht schon die
taste wird immer so ein bisschen weiße
denen da oben sind schon zwei fällig
jetzt fliege ich noch mal gegen darum
sind drei fertig und ich fliege nochmal
gegen und jetzt seht ihr meine lieben
freunde da wird der komplette
touchscreen kreiert mit den ganzen apps
die ich irgendwie nutzen kann das auf
jeden fall extrem reizt ich kann jetzt
hier erstmal in die einstellungen rein
fliegen sondern seht ihr schon kommen
hier die einstellungen und jetzt kann
ich beispielsweise mal einfach auf
pesket fliegen und jetzt können wir hier
das passwort ändern ich lasse das
passwort jetzt allerdings einfach mal so
kommen wir ändern das ganze jetzt mal
auf 1.111 das ist jetzt auch egal
damit ich euch einfach mal zeige dass
das ganze funktioniert also 1 1 1 und
noch mal die 1 und dann sieht es schon
wir sind wieder in den fertigungs und
das ganze funktioniert wir können auf
jeden general fliegen und dann seht ihr
schon select kann ja freunde wir können
die farbe bestimmen mein iphone ist
dieses space pace pace grauheding hier
es gibt sie allerdings nicht als aus
weil ich denke dass er soll es ein
bisschen darstellt ist allerdings erst
mal hier das blaue einfach nur damit ihr
seht das ist ganz auf funktioniert ich
fliege hiergegen und ihr seht schon mein
iphone ist blau
das sieht extrem cool das ist mega cool
wenn das einfach nicht funktionieren
würde wenn ich da einfach gegen den
iphone gegen fliegen würde und die also
einfach drauf drücken könnte die farbe
wird sich ändern
dann haben wir hier noch mega viele
andere sachen wie beispielsweise noch
paint da fliege ich mal eben gegen das
soll paint darstellen und hier wurde
jetzt schon ein wenig was gemalt und ich
kann jetzt hier auch einfach mal war sie
so gegen fliegen und ihr seht schon neu
hallo möchte nichts mal kollege was
jetzt los muss charged werden kann
verstehe ich gerade nicht normalerweise
wenn wenn ich paint öffnen muss ich
einfach nur dagegen fliegen und dann
müsste ich es beispielsweise hier
einfach so hier runter fliegen da man
nachricht zu sein endlich jetzt schnell
geschrieben
wieso es gerade nicht geht verstehe ich
nicht so genau vielleicht habe ich mir
die farbe weiß geholt kann das eventuell
seien auf jeden fall funktioniert halt
eigentlich auch paint also man kann
eigentlich auch sachen malen
das ist die pänz paint app dann haben
wir hier noch die notizen app da fliege
ich auch mal eben gegen da das hier ist
dann die notizen app da kann ich dann
quasi einfach irgendwelche notizen
hinschreiben wie beispielsweise hey ich
muss noch äpfel einkaufen da unten ist
es wieder braucht so ein bisschen bis
halb fertig geladen das einfach wegen
den rändern einstellungen also das sind
die notizen da kann ich dann quasi
wirklich einfach gegen passieren
schreiben was mir auf dem herzen liegt
dann haben wir halt noch diese normalen
apps wie beispielsweise safari die sind
allerdings nicht zum öffnen gedacht also
da kann ich jetzt nicht darauf zugreifen
da fliege ich war sie einfach gegen da
passiert nix die einzigen apps die ich
wirklich benutzen kann sind halt nahezu
hängt notizen wetter geht meine ich auch
also wenn ich mal gegen better fliege
wto freitag 21 grad extrem leicht wird
aber leider nie
also hier kann ich quasi einfach das
wetter nachschauen das ist natürlich
nicht mit dem internet verbunden sondern
ist es einfach nur vom geld das man sich
das wetter quasi anschauen kann
dann haben wir hier noch clock ist es
meine ich da bin ich mir gar nicht
sicher ob ich darauf zugreifen kann
ich glaube nämlich nicht mehr geht nicht
movies geht meine ich auch nicht da
diese anderen apps sind hier halt mehr
oder weniger nur so ein bisschen zum
damit man nicht nur damit man jetzt
nicht nur drei apps auf dem homescreen
hat allerdings was auch funktioniert ist
schläppi bertsch und zwar haben wir dann
hier fleckenberg wir können dann quasi
einfach wenn ihr auf dieses framework im
home menü können wir einfach hier
erscheinen dass ein staat partner kann
man hier auf start druck und dann wenn
man hier auf jump flick dann hüpft phase
dieser vogel allerdings ist das ganze
echt total am ruckeln das hab ich euch
ja schon gesagt und da mehr als
irgendwie einen score als 0 oder
irgendein anderes packen ist schon
extrem schwierig man muss dafür auch ein
bisschen näher dran sein meine ich damit
sich das ganze ein bisschen besser
rendert sodann kann mir hier mal auf
zusammenklicken also es ist wirklich ich
find's cool dass es überhaupt
funktioniert quasi einfach ein iphone
mit allen möglichen war kurz vor 1 das
war auf jeden fall die iphone 6 wanne
lamotte wir haben hier die ganzen apps
wie das hier angezeigt wird die ganzen
verschiedenen cases hier haben wir die
ganzen reds command blogs sachen ich
wollte es ersten die command blogs mit
dran nehmen allerdings war da wieder die
sache dass das ganze wieder extrem
langes und ist eine extra welt ist also
ihr findet in der beschreibung
einerseits den welt download und
einerseits das video von der person die
das ganze gemacht hat ich freue mich
dass es so was gibt einfach dass es auch
vernünftige iphones gibt und nicht nur
noch irgendwie sowas wo man dann nur
kaka machen kann sonst hoffe ich dass es
euch gefallen hat wenn es das getan hat
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen und wir sehen uns neu wird
einfach wieder rund auf und wir sehen
uns in einem weiteren video wieder